[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de la
prensa internacional esto con rosa
pressmás de euros a feliz en mañana de
martes abrimos esta revista de prensa
con el momento que dio sin duda la
vuelta al mundo el día de ayer en
noticieros de la noche de ayer lunes no
rosa una editora del canal 1 de noticias
de rusia irrumpió en medio de la
transmisión en protesta con la guerra en
ucrania buenos días raúl efectivamente
no probablemente mucha de nuestra
audiencia y habrá visto estas imágenes
pero vamos a contextualizar las
recordemos estas imágenes sucedieron
ayer en el llamado perfil canal que
vendría a ser algo así como cadena
primera canal 1 de rusia que es una
cadena de televisión con una
participación mayoritaria del estado no
se podría llamar una televisión estatal
como decías en el noticiero de la noche
mientras una de las presentadoras
estrella estaba explicando una noticia
sobre cómo rusia estaba intentando
mitigar los impactos negativos de las
sanciones impuestas por occidente contra
la economía rusa
en el en el directo la productora
también de canal uno marina opciã nico
va con un mensaje de protesta que si te
parece veamos a continuación adelante
pues rosa imágenes sin duda
valientes no también por parte de esta
editora porque pues ya está detenida
sabiendo todas las consecuencias además
con esta nueva ley rusa no pero como ha
cubierto esto la prensa alrededor del
mundo y precisamente en este territorio
en rusia bueno raúl pues como como
comentábamos no esté pues esta acción ha
tenido tanto impacto que incluso como
decías en el inicio de este programa
pues es portada de the gardian no y
vemos aquí una parte del eslogan que se
lee en éste carta en este cartel de
protesta es propaganda les están
mintiendo pero también encontramos esto
en la prensa ucraniana no en el de kiev
post también lo encontramos pues en el
universal de méxico de hecho pues en la
bbc- en el washington post pero
alrededor de todo el mundo y bueno en
todas partes se hace la traducción del
ruso en este caso lo traducimos al
español recordemos el cartel dice no a
la guerra este parte sí que está en
inglés con la bandera de ucrania la
bandera rusa luego dice detengan la
guerra no se crean la propaganda les
están mintiendo aquí y rusos contra la
guerra otra vez esta frase también en
inglés y mientras pues aparecía en el
plató gritaba no a la guerra rusos
contra la guerra antes de que la señal
fuera cortada como veíamos en las
imágenes por un reportaje pues grabado
de un hospital en rusia y
particularmente como me preguntaba raúl
en rusia esta noticia ha sido cubierta
de distintas formas distintas por un
lado vemos que en el moscú times y en la
medio medusa también la imagen aparece
en su integridad y de hecho fue un
periodista de medusa el que compartió en
twitter un mensaje que la productora o
ciani cova había dejado grabado para
publicar en sus redes sociales antes de
hacer esta acción o en este mensaje
explicaba lo que la motivó a irrumpir de
esta forma en protesta contra la guerra
ya decía que se avergonzaba de haber
trabajado durante tanto tiempo en este
canal de noticias y de haber participado
a la que la población rusa se
convirtiera en zombie ella explica que
su padre es ucraniano y que su madre
rusa y que nunca han sido en acusa a
putin de lanzar una guerra fraticida y
digamos que
pide a la población rosa que salga a las
calles a protestar que no pueden
encarcelar a todo el mundo rosa pero
vamos a tenerlos entonces en la forma
como aborda esta noticia el 'novaya
gazeta' y teme recordemos rosa que son
cientos de los rusos civiles incluso la
población pues de a pie que no está de
acuerdo con esta guerra pero también se
encuentra en la represión por parte del
gobierno vladímir putin en las calles
exactamente y un poco esquivar la
represión como dices es lo que intenta
este periódico no en nóvaya gazeta que
vemos que está para gran parte del
mensaje no de que muestra la productora
a las cámaras y solamente dejan la parte
que dice no crean la propaganda y en el
texto no explicativo porque esta foto
responde a lo que él nóvaya gazeta
titula foto del día pues en el pie de
foto señala que el rosco mayor digamos
en el regulador de las
telecomunicaciones y el código penal
tras la introducción de esta ley que
comentaba que castiga las calumnias
contra las fuerzas armadas rusas pues se
les prohíbe transmitir el com en el
comentario completo
también explica el nueva gaceta que
según las informaciones del abogado de
la ong hoy o de pues las últimas 12
horas no se han podido poner en contacto
con la productora que como decías pues
se encuentra detenida pero en un
paradero desconocido así es rosa pero
sin embargo no encontramos toda esta
información en toda la prensa rusa que
hemos tener como los que haya pravda y
en él vemos ti pues si rápidamente raúl
en el dedo mosto y por ejemplo
encontramos que esta semana esa semana
regional en rusia y esto implica que los
representantes de la duma se desplazan a
las distintas regiones para conocer de
cerca las problemáticas de la población
de a pie y como novedad se van a
desplazar a las autoproclamadas
repúblicas de donges y logan's para
digamos
promover la convergencia entre las
legislaciones rusa y de éstas
autoproclamadas repúblicas porque
recordemos que aunque de momento no se
trata de una anexión de estas repúblicas
por parte de rusia pues así que vladimir
putin la reconoció antes de empezar esta
invasión de ucrania
entre otras cosas destaca en su portada
esta mujer sollozando porque se ha
muerto su madre en este ataque pues
atribuido por parte de las autoridades
de la autoproclamada república de donges
a las fuerzas ucranianas en las que
habrían muerto 20 personas pues
precisamente en donges k rosa gracias
por toda la información saludamos a
nuestro primer invitado el día